[Müzik]
Öncelikle burada olduğum için Gerçekten
mutluyum Biraz önce dışarıya çıktım
gerçekten arkadaşlar Hani enerjisi ve
sinerjisi bana da geçti biraz genelde
böyle hazırlıklı Gelirim buraya ama
bugün hazırlıksız geldim kafamda bir şey
yok Onun için güzel bir dolaşlama ile
bunu bir özetleyeceğim size birinci
olarak atalarımızdan başlayayım
konuşmamı şöyle başlamak istiyorum
atalarımızı beslenmesi günümüz ve
gelecekle ilgili daha sonra da biraz
daha
nasıl söyleyeyim rahat konulara
geçeceğim ilk olarak Atalarımız nasıl
besleniyordu atalarımızın iyi
beslendiğini söyleyemeyiz Çünkü elinde
olan mevcut gıdalarla beslenmek
yolundaydı Çünkü o zamanlar
saklama yöntemleri ürünlerin saklama
yöntemleri veya işte tedariyi çok
sorundu mümkün olduğu kadar kısa ve
hızlı ve çabuk ulaşılabilir şeylerle
beslendiler
yaklaşık 1.700 de 1.800'lü yıllarda
patatesin daha Türkiye'ye geldiğini veya
Patlıcanın gelip de Öncelikle Avrupa'da
süs bitkisi olarak Hindistan'dan gelip
süs bitkisi olarak gelip kullanıldığı
zamanları düşünürsek Hatta ve hatta
Tabi o zamanlarda dini görüşler Daha
ağırlıklı özellikle Sebze ve meyvelerde
işte Amerika'dan gelen bir patates vardı
yaklaşık bir 50-60 sene gelen bu
koloninin islah tarafından getirilen
patatesler
kiliselerin bahçesinde yetiştirildi ve
topraktan geldiği için onların kötü
şeyler getirdiğine inanıldı ve ekilmedi
ne zaman ki işte salgınlar başladı şey
oldu Daha sonra kilise işte patatesi
Hani yiyoruz Ya hepimiz mcdonaldığında
birdenbire hayatımıza girdi Hatta ve
hatta domates özellikle Osmanlı'da
kırmızı yenilmiyordu Çünkü Yeşil olarak
yenilmesi bir lanet veya kötü bir şey
olduğuna inanıyorlardı tekrar başa
dönersek hem saklama hem pişirme olarak
biz gerçekten atalarımızdan daha
şanslıyız Şu anda
şu an anlatalım birazcık da atalarımızı
bir kenara bırakıyorum şu anda hepinizin
gördüğü gibi
hızlı bir beslenme modu var yani
oturmadan hızlı bir şekilde beslenelim
zaman kaybetmeyelim Çünkü zaman çok
önemli Fakat bu tarafta da unuttuğumuz
bir şey var Aslında o da hepimizin belki
sizler 40'lı yaşlar diyelim işte
ailemizin oturup hep birlikte yemek
yediğimiz işte akşam yemeklerini
birlikte tükettiğimiz Zamanlar geçti
artık Bakıyorum Mesela
özellikle gençlere bakıyorum
ne yapalım işte hep dışarıda yiyelim
Okey cuma cumartesi Hadi bir eller
havaya gidelim Okey Pazar günü de bir
kahvaltıya geçelim şöyle bir Van
serpmesi yapalım falan derken
ne zaman geliyor evde yemek pişirme zili
ne zaman ki evde çocuk oluyor evde yemek
zili çalmaya başlıyor O evde
bekar çiftler için söylüyorum yemek
başlıyor ondan sonra bugüne kadar
olmayan organik olmayan Anneler bir
bakıyorsunuz organik pazarlarda Çünkü
çocuklarına organik yedirmek istiyorlar
ne yapıyorlar İşte bu havuç şöyle şu
işte patates böyle bunu alayım onu
alayım falan filan böyle şeylere
giriyorlar ama sorunu sorulması gereken
şey şu bugüne kadar neredeydin
niye kendin değerli değilmişsin yani Sen
çocuğun kadar değerli değil misin
kendini niye sağlıklı besleniyorsun veya
sormuyorsun hepiniz Çarşı pazara
gidiyorsunuzdur Ben biliyorum
ya da Annenizle ya da arkadaşlarınızla
mesela gittiğiniz zaman bir bakın mesela
koymuşlar işte domatesler
hasberk Eda sanki Allah'ın kelamı bu bu
Okeydir Arkadaşlar bunu gidin alın yiyin
gibi bir durum ortaya çıkıyor Çünkü öyle
alışmışız hiç sorgulamıyoruz nereden
geliyor nasıl yapılıyor kim yetiştiriyor
hiçbir şey yok ortada Ama öbür taraftan
bakıyorsunuz Televizyon kanallarına
şeylere İşte şu üründe şu bulunmuş geri
gönderilmiş Burada şu bulunmuş ve geri
gönderilmiş gibi oldu Şimdi başka bir
konuya geçeceğim o da annelerin gittiği
organik pazarlar dünyada arkadaşlar
organik tarım müthiş ilerliyor yani her
sene bir üstüne 20 milyar 30 milyar
dolara artıyor koyarak artıyor
Trend'de Türkiye'nin yerini Türkiye'nin
yeri şu anda mesela İstanbul büyük bir
Metropol 20 milyon nüfusu var ve
bunlarda kaç tane organik pazarlar
biliyor musunuz bilmiyorsunuz Ben
söyleyeyim iki tane 20 milyonluk bir
şeyi öbür tarafa bakıyorsunuz Avrupa'da
herhangi bir 200 binlik 250 binlik bir
şehirde organik pazar miktarı 5 ile 10
arasında
bizse o iki pazara hala şey göze
bakıyoruz diyor ki bakalım diyor bunda
diyor etiketlerde bir şey olabilir belki
bu değil diyor tüketen insan Belki de
bizi kandırıyorlar diyor ben bunu şunun
için anlattım yani organik pazar ve
dünya organiğe doğru koşarken biz hala
bir şeyleri sorgulamakla vakit
geçiriyoruz
şimdi organik de şu da var organik
pazarda Bu bir katma değer yani ülkenize
para kazandırıyorsunuz ürettiğiniz zaman
en büyük tüketiciler Almanya ve Avrupa
baktığınız zaman en büyük üreticiler de
fakir ülkeler işte Hindistan var
Afrika'da ülkeler var Bunlar ihraç
ediyor Yani biz bunlara
Bunlar bunları yaparken biz bu konunun
neresindeyiz ve niye bu kadar geride
kaldık Aslında konuşulması ve
araştırılması gereken şey bu Çünkü dünya
artık zenginleşiyor artık 20 sene 30
sene 40 sene önceki gibi değil Dünyamız
daha çok zenginleşiyor zenginleşen insan
da otomatik olarak daha iyi beslenmeye
daha iyi yaşam Standartları ve daha iyi
koşullar arıyor Bunlardan biri de
organik yemekler organik yiyecekler
dünya Buraya doğru koşuyor Yani ben öyle
öngörüyorum ki herhalde bir 10 sene
içinde bu 130-140 milyar dolarlık şey
bir trilyon dolara ulaşacak bir trilyon
dolardan konuşuyorum bu bir fırsat Eğer
konum ve yer tutabilirseniz Bu pazarda
sizin için güzel bir fırsat ve kaldı ki
toprağın ve suyun Ben konuşmacılarını da
dinledim toprağın ve suyun bu kadar çok
kirlendiği bir ülkede Yani dünyada bizim
gerçekten kullanılabilir organik tarım
arazilerimiz var Belki bunlara bir el
atılabilir veya projelerle
desteklenebilir özellikle gençlerin de
katılımıyla bunların sulama teknikleri
yetiştirilme teknikleri diye Şimdi tarım
veya bu organik tarım deyip geçmeyin
arkadaşlar yani baktığınız zaman bir
Hollanda üçte ikisi denizden Kazanılmış
bir ülke deniz toprağıyla daha sonra
bunun üstüne bir tarım yapılıyor ve şu
anda Avrupa'nın en büyük tarım
üreticisi ve dünyada da top 20'de
ekonomik olarak yani neyin nereye
gittiğini iyi bakmak gerekiyor
bir diğer konum özellikle
şimdi tarım sadece
tarlada yapılmıyor Bir de deniz tarımı
var deniz üstündeki tarımlar var işte
balık yetiştirme çiftlikleri efendime
söyleyeyim mi
kabuklulara kadar bu da ayrı bir mecra
ve biz burada da biraz geride kaldık
yani
toplam
8300 km
etrafımız suyla kaplı
ve bizim hepinizin bildiği balık oranı 5
5 tane
bunlardan levreği Çıktım çuprayı Çıktım
hamsi zaten sürü halinde geziyor hepimiz
bekliyoruz değil mi hepimiz bekliyoruz
sezon gelsin balık yiyelim doğru mu
sezonun dışında yiyebiliyor muyuz
yiyemiyoruz Çünkü çok pahalı alamıyoruz
işte sorulması gereken sorulardan biri
de bu yani Biz 8.300 km uzunluğundaki
Marmara dese 4 tane denizden neden 5 tür
balık alıyoruz
neden Marmara'da 147 çeşit balık türü
yok oldu kirlenmeden ve şeyden dolayı
Yani bir yerde de belki kendi şeyimizi
baltalıyoruz Yani belki birazcık şey
oldu karamsar oldu ama şöyle
toparlayayım hepsinin bir çözümü var
Özellikle bir kaç sene denizlerimizin
nadasa bırakırlarak hiçbir avlanma
yapılmadan belki birazcık toparlanması
sağlanabilir Belki bu çok fazla olan
deniz avlanma işte gemilerinin birazcık
daha irileştirip açık denizleri
okyanuslara da avlanması gibi hani
diyoruz ya İstanbul'a gelmişsinizdir
balık ekmek yemişsinizdir muhakkak
Eminönü'nde
işte adamlar öyle bir teknoloji yapıyor
ki işte pasifiye gidiyor gemi Efendim
avlanıyor kesiliyor paketleniyor
donduruluyor Bir Gemi Geliyor hop onu
alıyor götürüyor ve siz o balıkları
yiyorsunuz yani buralara doğru belki
kayabiliriz diye düşünüyorum
Bir diğer konumda özellikle beslenme ve
pişirme ile ilgili
beslenme ile ilgili konumda şunu
söyleyeyim
İstanbul'da özellikle 20 milyonluk bir
Metropol Ankara'nın bilmiyorum nüfusu
kaç ama 20 milyon üstünden gideyim ben
Yaklaşık 3 öğün yemek tüketildiğini
düşünürsek yaklaşık
60 milyon öğün yapıyor günde
ayda 1 milyar 800 milyon öğün yemek
tüketiliyor İstanbul ve içinde
çevresinde öyle konuşalım tabii bunların
denetlenmesi bir an için düşünün bir
milyar 800 milyon öğün yemek bunların
denetlenmesi gelen malların denetlenmesi
nereden geliyor nasıl geliyor Nasıl bize
ulaşılıyor bunların denetlenmesi ve şey
gerçekten çok zor gerçekten çok zor ve
beslenmede size tavsiyem şimdi tavsiye
kısmına geçeyim
ürünü takip etmeye çalışın bildiğiniz
yerden ve bildiğiniz yerlerden alışveriş
yapmayı veya yönlendirme yapmayı tercih
edin çünkü
Bilmeden bir şeyi alıp tüketmek ileride
sağlık olarak bize çok zararı olabilir
zararlı olabilir onun için ufak böyle
size örnek notlar söylüyorum
özür dilerim
beslenme de bir diğer hususumuz da
özellikle
evde yemek olayı biz hiç yapmıyoruz
ancak gidiyoruz işte evde annemiz
pişirmişse babamız pişirmişse bunu
yapıyoruz bunun için belki iki tane şey
Önerim vardı benim birincisi özellikle
İlkokullarda hava güzel olduğu zaman bir
günün tarlada yapılması derslerin
ilkokul çocuklarının özellikle yani
tavuklar nereden geliyor domates nereden
çıkıyor işte hayvan sevgisi doğa sevgisi
bunları vermek
birinci olarak ben bunu öneriyorum
ikinci olarak da ürün takibi yani
üretilen ürünleri kim denetliyor nasıl
denetliyor işte Biraz önce söylediğim 1
milyarı 800 milyon öğünlük bir pasta
düşünün Bunu kim denetleyecek Nasıl
denetleyecek ve ne yiyeceğiz Ne
yiyeceğiz
bunların haricinde de birkaç şey daha
ilave etmek istiyorum herhalde bir 5
dakikam daha var
kendimiz özellikle üniversiteye giden
arkadaşlar için söylüyorum genelde bir
şey yapamadığı için yani daha doğrusu
bilmediği için üniversitedeki
arkadaşlarımız hep dışarıdan alıyor veya
arkadaşlarıyla oluşuyor hepiniz
üniversitelisiniz Hepiniz zaten bunları
yaşıyorsunuz benim görüşüm müfredatta
özellikle liselerde bir yemek dersi
verilmesi yani liselerde En azından bir
makarna nasıl haşlanır Ne bileyim bir
patates nasıl yapılır 2 yumurta nasıl
kırılır bunları göstermek Bence Önemli
çünkü
ileri ki dönemde şu yaşlarınızda Bunlar
Gerçekten size faydalı olabiliyor Bir de
erkek arkadaşlara söylüyorum yemek
pişiren erkek arkadaşlar romantik
erkektir Ayrıca söyleyeyim size Çünkü
ilgilenmeniz Birine bir şey hazırlamanız
o şeyi tatmanız güzel bir şey be karşı
tarafa da hissettirmeniz onu sunmanız
beğenilmesi her zaman güzel oluyor
Başka size anlatacağım Bir şey daha
vardı da onu düşünüyorum Böyle dolaştım
olacak unutuyoruz Maalesef
o da hayatla ilgili bir iki tane tavsiye
vermek istiyorum çünkü çok
kurumsal dinliyorsunuz zaten bütün gün
hocalarınızdan ve şeyden ama ben birkaç
şeyi size paylaşmak istiyorum hayatımda
Çünkü 4 kıtada çalıştım yaklaşık 25
yılım yurt dışında geçti
Bu da hayatla ilgili olan şeyimiz şu;
Bizler
hep 100 metre koşmak istiyoruz hiç
maraton koşmak istemiyoruz herkes
bakıyorum gençlere bakıyorum kapağı
Bodrum'a atayım kapağı Avrupa'ya atayım
kapağı Almanya'ya atayım işte kapağı
başka bir tarafa atayım ama kısa
mesafeli koşullarda Evet bir şey
kazanabilirsiniz ama gerçek başarı
maraton koşullarında oluyor uzun süreli
koşularda bu hem İş hayatınızda geçerli
hem sosyal hayatınızda geçerli Hem
ailevi hayatınıza geçerli bunu paylaşmak
istemiştim
Bir de son söz olarak süremde bitiyor
zaten
hayatın renklerine ve insanların
kalplerine dokunmayı sakın unutmayın
hayat bu ikisi arasında gidip geliyor
Hepinize çok teşekkür ediyorum beni
dinlediğiniz için sağ olun
[Müzik]